[Music]
all right let's go Westbrook is ready
I'm telling you he's got energy this
morning and it might be because right in
front of them is a [ __ ] Reese's Cup
whoa you learned a lot about the people
of the internet this past week didn't
you Brian you know what I know about
Reese's now I feel that the people that
love this candy they're there first of
all they're mean people
mean spirits they're evil what was your
mentions they're not very nice they're
not very nice people I have people that
have followed me since my rookie year
tell me to my face on Twitter I don't
like this on Twitter I don't respect you
anymore I don't respect your opinion
anymore these have been fans of mine I
saw a lot here saying that you had CTE a
lot of people felt like I've had too
many concussions that the peanut butter
and chocolate deserve to deserve each
other I mean it's been a bad week for me
it's not a bad week speaking for all the
people out there that enjoy food way too
much yeah there's this emotional
attachment that we have to certain
flavors mm-hmm
you know what I mean like you got that
one pizza you take that bite you're back
to that one date you had back when you
were trying to write you eat that Mike
and Ike and you're you know you're
seeing Thumbelina in theaters all over
again Reese's Peanut Butter Cup is a
flavor that we all have when we need a
pick-me-up and we need a friend yeah and
you pretty much came out there and said
[ __ ] your friend it's a comfort food
yeah it's like your best friend but it's
a food I'll say this on the other side
there were some people that said you
know what I felt like this for a very
long time
Wow but they were afraid because of my
courage because of my courage to come
out there and say peanut butter and
chocolate don't belong together they
were finally able to say you know what I
feel the same way Wow and they have
nobody but me to thank for that
that's incredible so here I am so your
your Walker you know just separating
you're welcome
separating chocolate and peanut butter
they don't belong to God alone what is
this what is this
yeah okay I can't eat that but I want to
your human diet what I just I just made
a bet with McAfee McAfee honest so you
lose weight well because I just no I
just thought I saw him like eating the
ends of croissants and stuff yeah yeah
and like that's what I do
mm-hm and I was like I need to lose like
15 20 pounds are you gonna go down 15 so
we're gonna we're gonna compete and now
that I because the thing is if it was
just for me I probably wouldn't district
cuz I'd be like yeah but I like eating
food but now that I know that I'm
competing against some honey yeah we're
gonna go like vegans you're gonna stay
focused in a gin I'm gonna do the gym
after work today Jim see that's what
always happens that people don't work
outs they always say I'm gonna lose
weight they go straight to the gym don't
put me in with those people you know
what I believe this is what I do cardio
nothing anything
this is what you do [ __ ] this is the
easiest way to lose weight I'm trying to
tell you you don't have to go to the gym
I never go to the gym and I lose weight
a lot no no no that's part of it too but
you have to eat somewhat healthy but
instead of eating the whole portion just
eat half of which you normally yeah but
I can't do that you have to have some
self-control what I've learned is my
self-control is putting small portions
in front of me that's what I'm saying
eat half yeah but I can't know that
there's more in the fridge Wow no
self-control man none yours but you're
stronger than that that surprises me
because it seems like you would have
self-control I do in almost everything
in my life but except food like when I
would be in former relationships when
those people would go out of town I
would eat like a [ __ ] that's a
man thing that's not okay that's not
that's a man thing yeah but my wife goes
out of town Oh pizza sometimes I eat a
little fast food yeah Oh nacho with a
few months ago in this podcast we were
doing eat like a homie yeah I was doing
great yeah yeah and then I fell off the
wagon
football season man there's just so much
stuff going on you're working so much I
just doesn't eat and crazy you're right
about that
oh how was the Eagles game Sunday the
Eagles game was other than an absolutely
boring and it was also surprising
surprising because I thought the Eagles
offense who I think I felt like they
gained some momentum
from the curb a game no I thought they
would just go out there and just bash
that just even though to just have a
pretty decent defense yeah I just
thought the day would overwhelm him and
just go up and down the field
14 points for the offense yeah that was
a touchdown I wasn't I wasn't impressed
by that no that's that's why my
confidence meter is probably like it was
a 6.9 for last two weeks I'm probably
like a six point seven mine is returned
to the range of five point six as we it
was it was a much lower yeah it's come
back up to five point six I'm concerned
again three distinct three tough games
ahead and then it all started and that
offense has not looked great however
defense has looked a little better
alright so I want to get right to
something I'm very excited about you
guys blew up our mentions you were
texting me and all of you said I love
dolphin tank it's my favorite thing
you've got a lot of fun so I don't even
know wait anymore let's get after it
look last week we bought some
interesting things we're not sure about
Tampa Bay and guess what you were right
Tampa Bay went out there to New Orleans
and it didn't work out I'm surprised by
that I I had a feeling that Tampa Bay
would figure out a way to score 30-plus
points mean even though the Saints
defense is now proven that they're
actually a little bit better than I
thought I am more emboldened with my
take that this that and this was one of
mine that the Saints are going to the
end to the Superbowl they're three and
Oh mm-hmm
without Drew Brees that's right and I
have now oh and three in the Super
contest betting against the Saints yeah
I'm not [ __ ] doing it anymore I
wouldn't do it if I was there defense is
so good at defense I'm trying to figure
out what were my other ones that I tried
to sell you one last week so one of them
of course was the Bay Buccaneers the
Panthers having a top five defense and
they look pretty good against
Jacksonville and the Saints are the best
team in the NFC and I think you know
what two for three
not bad I think so but it's time is it
the second installment let's do it of
Delfin tank
welcome back to dolphin tank we're left
go pitches his exciting new NFL
investment ideas to venture capitalist
Brian Westbrook
dolphin tank it's a pun because it
sounds like shark tank and the Dolphins
are tanking this year get it okay first
up in the tank left go has a surefire
playoff team but always seems to be
never the bride always the bridesmaid
he's looking for a 15% equity stake in
this take and if he doesn't get it he
might just leave the room and destroy
some furniture
okay I have a team for you that is a
lock for the playoffs and they're not
the Patriots and they're not the Chiefs
and they're not the Saints there's a
team that people are they're excited
about but they're not sure
and I'm telling that they're a lock okay
this team are you looking at the teams
I'm asking you I'm looking at the teams
I mean I want you I want you to put it
away
okay go ahead let's go I don't know go
go okay
this team is four and one don't [ __ ]
look I'm not gonna let go ahead so they
have four wins okay
this team still gets to face at home the
Jets the Washington Redskins and the
Broncos fair to say that seven wins
possibly at least okay this team also
gets to face the Dolphins twice that's
nine wins yeah are you buying my team as
a lock for the playoffs so there'll be a
wild-card right so they may even even
told you the other games yes I mean that
they're a wild card in there in the AFC
right have to be I'm just gonna give you
it they have to be the bills right so I
am saying the bills
okay I'll lock for the plows in Lock not
fighting for a wild-card spot let me
read that one more time the Jamie what
do you mean they're not fighting for a
wild-card spot I'm saying that they have
to fight for a wild-card spot but what
I'm saying is is they'll be like the
Chargers were last year we're they're
like the five seed and it's clear and
everyone else is fighting for right
right right right right okay they have
four wins mm-hmm they still have the
Jets the Redskins and Broncos at home
right the Dolphins twice they still they
get the they get Pittsburgh at
Pittsburgh with whatever that
quarterback situation is and they get
the Ravens at home yeah that's winnable
yeah I think that this is like a minimum
nine win team I think I think you're
right I think they went between
nine games yeah and I think if something
crazy happen yeah I can believe that
you're buying this tape I would buy that
I'll buy the building because listen
again week five Kevin you have a defense
that's gonna play lights-out you have a
running young running game that I think
can continue to evolve but you also have
a quarterback when healthy has the
ability to throw the ball and run and
that's important especially you playoff
time you need a defense to be off
balance
and to be thinking about a lot of
different things a quarterback that has
the ability to run we saw it last year
who from Lamar Jackson changes the
dynamic of football games the Buffalo
Bills whenever they would miss the
playoffs would lose that game to the
Titans yes in terms of they go out there
they beat the Patriots they come back
the next week now I will say this for
people that didn't watch the game the
Titans missed for feel good yes Oh
Santos went over for yeah
but the Buffalo Bills were still all
over Mariota and it's very important to
me that the defense travels yes
sometimes these zone defenses that are
really good underneath they get shredded
when they go on the road a little bit
that's Mariota but I I don't think
people look at the schedule enough like
I look at the Jets right now I this
might be the best thing that's ever
happened to Sam darn 'old because when
you looked at the Jets schedule before
he comes back those first seven weeks
were absolutely awful for the Jets they
were playing the bills we now knows a
great defense seems Browns
Patriots Eagles Cowboys Patriots Jaguars
so those first seven games for the Jets
were gonna be awful yes right but then
guess what Dolphins Giants Washington
Raiders bengals dolphins darn 'old is
gonna come back in the second half and
look great and it's just funny because
we always look at the schedules and
beginning of the year and not halfway
through and so the Bengal the the Jets
and the bills the fact that they both
get to play the Dolphins twice helps its
enormous no other team has that right I
think the bills right now because of
their schedule have a front-row seat at
that five seat in the blood I think
the schedule certainly plays a big part
in it but I think when you have a
defense that can go anywhere especially
you're a wild card team that can go
anywhere and gives you a chance to win
you add that to a quarterback that can
move around that gives that puts you in
at every turn say at halftime if you're
on the road is 14 to 7 and you're down
by 7 you're in the game you have a
chance to win especially if your defense
gives a timely turnover huh a great
opportunity for the bills in the last
few weeks they've done it without Devin
Singletary he hasn't played who I think
is a phenomenal dynamic packed enjoy
with Frank or should be interesting all
right Frank Gore continues to get it
done which is he's the man may think
he's averaging close to fabulous okay
next up on dolphin tank next into the
tank Lefko believes a certain team may
just be the most underrated squad in the
NFL he wants five million dollars in
exchange for a zero percent equity stake
because it's his show and he's allowed
to ask for outlandish things
sounds about right are you interested
well I'll tell you this from the
beginning I have a problem with the
whole premise of this dog or a dolphin
tank thing why because I don't get to
ask questions about the team you tell me
these non-existent remote no context
stats and I just got to say yes or no
yeah it's called media well I mean I
need to be able to overreaction to be
able to ask questions like hey like a
real venture capitalist yeah okay go
okay and I won't ask question just know
you can ask questions I just don't like
when you look at the teams I can't look
at the teams the list of the teams
because I think I'm not looking at the
record I'm looking at the list the team
that's it okay I have a three into team
okay that everyone wrote off before the
season even started okay
the two teams that this team lost to a
combined seven and three and one of
those teams is the Chiefs okay in this
team's three wins their quarterback was
sacked just one time and lost zero yards
and this included playing against Von
Miller and Khalil Mack okay I believe
they're the most underrated team in the
NFL what do you think
zero percent stake five nine dollars ask
I have her questions you want okay so we
always talk about defense how is their
defense or quality the Canadian asset a
great average can they get out to the
quarter but their defensive lot they're
able to get some pressure with just
their front four and their defensive
line is
really good against the room any
injuries especially its it up secondary
a major injury on their offensive line
that people I don't think realize there
are injuries in their secondary but
their secondary is done pretty good okay
turnovers next question to ask question
turnovers how are they internal I'm
going to look it up right now what's the
turnover ratio luckily I have the
beautiful NFL Jesus right now they are
-1 so they they have six giveaways five
takeaways I will this sounds like a
playoff caliber team possibly it's a
wild car team that means that means when
I say that that means let's just say
they are in the AFC West and there are
two dog going Raiders yes that's exactly
I'm talking about perfect they have a
chance to make it but you know there's
some other things obviously the the
Chargers are going the wrong way and
they have a tough schedule ahead I think
that the the Raiders have a good core of
guys and they're getting great
contributions from the running back and
that starts to allow that offense to
kind of roll downhill
I think Tyrell Williams is gonna is a
stud I really he missed this lesson he
didn't he still won and they still play
so I just I think that the Raiders as
are not a lot buying them a little bit I
would Biden actually I think that I
would buy the Raiders to me or this team
that because of hard knocks because of
Antonio Brown when he left I think
everybody crossed them off there in
their minds and said we don't need to
worry about them I think that people
felt that way even before the season
started but I always thought the Raiders
were a positive regression team that
could bounce back this year after last
year the other thing is too is when you
look at their games they went to
Indianapolis same Indy team that we just
saw be the Chiefs yeah and pretty much
beat him a lot more than that 3124
physically beat them like beat them
physically yes
beat him up then they plays Chicago and
they physically beat them like not only
the clio Mac not get a sack that oftens
a line for the Raiders was pushing them
around the entire game I know because I
bet the bear
right when you bet a game you're
watching everything and I wrote down my
notes four or five times the Raiders are
doing whatever they want the Raiders yes
they ended up winning that game barely
they had a drive where they went all the
way down to the one and then a backup
wide receiver traverse Davis that used
to be on the Packers fumbled on the goal
line so they could have been up by two
scores but the thing about the Raiders
that's so interesting is they lose
vantes Burfict the other defense okay
they lose Antonio Brown they make it
work Richie incognito was suspended for
the first two games comes back and guess
what I believe possibly their best
offensive lineman Gabe Jackson when he
gets back in about two three weeks this
offensive line that has Trent Brown
that's a monster
Colton Miller who's playing pretty well
as a first-round pick
Rodney Hudson who's a stud Richie
incognito which is a mauler and now
they're gonna get Gabe Jackson like I
said in there three wins Derek Carr has
been sacked one time for no yards
Josh Jacobs has holes every single play
I want to formally apologize because I
talked about how the Raiders we're gonna
get their ass kicked in London and all
the Raiders fans jump in my mentions and
say are you gonna apologize let me just
say this fucking-a of course like I hope
you got and maybe it's like new
listeners that I'm not used to we
believe in self scouting if you believe
in admitting when we were wrong self
assessment and and I am NOT one of these
media people that's gonna go out there
and be like no [ __ ] you it was against
chase Daniel no the Raiders offensive
and defensive lines are deep and they
are powerful and they are angry and they
are mean and if you are not ready to
play them they are gonna punch you in
the face and the NFL is better when the
raid is are good and I'm loving what I'm
seeing you said something that's so
important to the NFL in general winning
in the trenches offensive and defensive
line if you can win there you got a
chance as long as you don't turn the
ball over and a couple laws they had
they're turning a ball no with Derek
Carr throwing the ball to the other team
if you could win in the trenches you got
a chance you add a running game to that
you got a chance you got a defense it's
not giving up big place you got a
chance to win the good part for them is
that they're in a vision where you know
they're not gonna be Kansas City but
they could beat the other two teams oh
yeah absolutely and so they're they have
an outside chance again to the the
wild-card the other thing is that Jon
Gruden and people make fun of him all
the time thinks he's a TV TV personality
things like that he has a good way of
rallying those troops and I think he has
a good relationship with the guys on the
team because he did back Antonia brown
until it was just too late you know he
did put this team in the situation
obviously they understand he'd let
Khalil Mack go last year big mistake
however these guys are saying listen we
got some draft picks out of that now we
have to go for it and win they're
playing with a chip on their shoulder
everybody else said you're not good
enough you're not gonna be able to get
it done this team is playing with the
chip on their shoulder and they've
played very well six intercepts assuming
six touchdowns three interceptions for
Derek Carr I said after the first game
if Derek Carr could play like the Derek
Carr that we saw yes before the leg
injury this team has a chance he's
getting there he's playing better he has
over 72 percent passing completions and
as far as his passing goes that's going
to help you a lot especially in this
office I think that excites me the most
is so Jon Gruden was the guy that what
now Kyle Shannon obviously learned from
his dad and but Sean McVeigh came under
Gruden Kyle Shanahan worked under Gruden
for a long time and I saw a few plays
yesterday in Chicago where the whole
offense ran right and the tight end run
left and he and all the space in the
world yeah Gruden is still able to dial
up a player to every drive that catches
the other team off-guard
there was a lot of penalties yesterday
and we're gonna get into these refs
because I believe right now were we're
in the worst era of roughing that I've
ever seen and I know that it's it's
hyperbolic but I feel you know I'm so
[ __ ] annoyed and the thing is man is
this industry went from a billion-dollar
industry to a multi-billion dollar
industry
now that betting is so big and I'm just
letting you know that when there's money
in all these games and I got Walt
[ __ ] Anderson doing the Steelers
Ravens game and he's calling like I bet
on the Ravens and I'm just gonna let you
know though
the reason the Ravens went to overtime
is they called a roughing the passer on
the Steelers that wasn't ours it was a
terrible call this al River on
protecting the referees by never
challenging anything and saying that's
the call on the field the referees on
the field don't know if they're supposed
to blow the whistle or go to the review
and because they didn't blow the whistle
al river on goes well we're not going to
overturn it but the only reason they
didn't blow their whistle was to let you
review it we are in this middle ground
of [ __ ] right now these referees a
few of them are in their upper 60s and I
don't want to be an ageist
but I'm saying not only are you not
physically able to probably run as fast
as you should but also you covered the
NFL you were roughing it 30 years ago
and the rules are so different you see
the speed of the game is so different
they can't get new referees because
they're not full-time jobs they're not
paid that much and all you're doing is
getting ridiculed but all I'm saying is
every [ __ ] game I'm watching the
calls are awful the offensive pass
interference the defensive pass
interference that are being called and
they're not being called the roughing
the passer it's awful and I know it's an
easy rant to go on every year yeah but
with al River Ron and his team coming
out every Monday and going everything
was great we're not having the time to
sit down and evaluate it what they're
lying to our face here's the thing about
the referees first of all you're talking
about a billion-dollar business multi
billions of billions of dollars business
why aren't the referees full-time that
that does it just doesn't make sense and
I know it's hard you can only work in
one day a week but that should be
full-time personal make them full-time
in the offseason guess what [ __ ] go
to boot camp
every [ __ ] we tit and they should be
in shape too so that that's one thing
but I really believe that the reps are
in a bad position I think they're in a
bad spot because the NFL say okay well
here's the rules now and we want you to
kind of judge a little bit different in
the playoffs and oh oh it's preseason
judging a little bit different do all
these different things but still all
play by these one sets of set of rules I
think they're in a bad spot
oh don't blow the whistle then we'll
just review it later I mean so you're
going to get your natural instinct and
so just like a player
where you want your players to just go
out there and be natural just be
instinctual now the referees are
thinking this a penalty is that under
the flag and should I build a whistle
and so they're confused and now they're
saying let's go to replay the biggest
problem that I had with the refs is
simply this you go to replay now you
have everything in a vacuum
you know the situation yeah time is
stopped yeah just get it right and they
still [ __ ] it up and I still get it
wrong all the time that's the biggest
problem now I listen hi I'm Jason
Garrett who all he does is clap
challenge flag and threw it down and
started yelling at the guy that play
wasn't close though that was the aryans
Bruce Arians
almost had a heart attack on the side
yeah Mike Tomlin was sitting there
dumbfounded these coaches are so
confused right now it makes no sense I'm
gonna show you one clip on my phone of
something that was ruled an interception
yesterday by Devon Bush and the reason
it was ruled that was because that was
the ruling on the field okay tell me if
this is a catch no no it was called an
interception of course it was there was
there were six plays in the Ravens
Steelers game yesterday where I just sat
there and was like they can they know
the spread like they know the spread
like every time the Ravens start going
up a little bit more oh there was one
play where Deonte
Deante Johnson okay went and then he
took two steps and the ball popped out
and it went out of bounds and then they
ruled it a catch and it was clearly an
incomplete pass and then if it was a
catch then it's a fumble right like I'm
so angry every to every Sun I just kind
of feel like the rest you just so
confused that things are changing all
the time and I think you have a point
that's hard the age of the refs in what
was going on thirty years ago compared
to what's going on now not that they
can't adjust but it's hard to see it
you've seen it totally different and
it's hard to keep up with mean how many
times do you hear the specialty ref and
the booth who was probably a referee for
two years that gets up there and goes
well this is clearly incomplete and then
it's complete and they're like
know what they're doing I've heard it in
every game every week every on Sunday
night with Kansas City yeah all right I
need to come same thing all right last
dolphin tank finally left go is pitching
one particular player as the number one
offensive weapon in the NFL spoiler
alert it's not John Franklin Myers who
both plays defense and is injured in
exchange for a 50% stake in this idea
left go is looking for $10 because it's
not about the money man
well it's about the money always about
the money that was good
this player no matter what position is
the best weapon in the NFL hmm
terms of rushing and receiving yards
combined number one the NFL he has two
games where he's had over 24 carries he
has two games with ten catches he has
two of the five the longest rushing
touchdowns the NFL this year he can
score from anywhere and right now he is
on pace to out gain Chris Johnson he has
the NFL record for 2,500 this guy's on
pace for nearly 2800 mm-hmm I believe
this guy is the best weapon in the NFL
and you know it is you know pushing
McCaffrey you know damn well it's
crushed him again I'll say this and and
I'm buying that all day long
based on everything the best weapon yeah
I'm buying that all day long and I all
Christian McCaffrey an apology tell him
because Christian I'm sorry
there were times where I saw your game
coming out of Stanford and I didn't see
it evolving into this I didn't say you
put on 15 pounds and becoming this
running back I didn't see you carrying a
load 25 times a game and we knew you
could catch out there back up I'm not
I'm not surprised by that I didn't see
doing this running the football and
catching out of the backfield and
basically carrying this football team
this football team is oh and two of CAM
as a quarterback
they've been three and know since cam
has been out there three you know and
he's averaging a hundred and forty one
rushing yards per game
yeah he has five touchdowns total in
those three games and he's averaging six
yards of carry I didn't I didn't see it
coming I didn't see him and I'll tell
you one thing that I saw come out of
college I saw it he looked a little
stiff
there was common situation where he was
a little stiff and not able to change
gears and and make people miss a little
wiggle he has that now I saw it I
watched all of his runs yesterday and
the little wiggle he has that so he's
making people miss at the second level
that's that's the extra three four yards
it's not as someone tackles you
that's an extra long run because he also
has a speed he's you know he's not
changing the game he has changed who he
is as a player he's gotten much better
in couple of weeks ago I would have took
it Alvin a camara before I took
Christian McCaffrey but now I don't know
that Comerica care that carry the load
all physically as far as running the
same way as McCaffrey can't so I would
take McAfee episode yeah I was good ran
everything that that he's doing right
now looks good
yeah and that's what you want out of
your running back that's what the
running backs are all trying to be these
these days it's it's incredible to watch
I always ask this question if if
balichek could go around the league and
steal one player from every team who
would be the guy he steals yeah he goes
to the Rams and he picks up Aaron Donald
but I think of all the offensive players
if you gave him all the offensive
players I believe McCaffrey not just the
fact that he's white being the Patriots
who always have white guy that helps
yeah but McCaffrey is the guy that he
can line up at tailback and carry it 27
times against Houston he can line up at
slot receiver or against the Texas I
think in eight catches and and catch ten
catches a game he can lay out he can he
can jump over people and Moss people he
can jump over people who look at one
from people he can flip over people in
the endzone like it's nothing I've seen
him stiff arm people into the ground
looks much stronger and much more agile
this year he's loosened his hips up he's
a much better player his acceleration
where he jumps and lands and can
immediately pick up so you owe me $10
for this take you owe me your money
oh you monies well you bought the take
for 10 bucks that's it I'll take that
you're selling them cheap but I'll take
that running back so cheap these days
they are I'll take that but I look at
Christian McCaffrey and when he comes up
for a contract
I think he's gonna blow it out of the
water because he's not just a running
back but he needs to be paid like a bell
Cal but also a slot receiver because
look it doesn't work that way I wish you
did know you're not I'm not arguing with
you I wish it did because I think that
he is so special and not remember me
going through it and when I was playing
and I didn't have as many carries as he
had but only thing that offensive
especially when it comes down and pay
for either saying well you're running
back with your rushing yards looked like
fortunately enough for him he has the
rushing attempts and the yard so he
looks good in that situation but if
you're talking about an offense and your
offensive coordinator
this is the exact guy that you're
looking for before you look for a
big-time receiver this is the guy that
you want because this is the guy that
now when he's in the game defenses have
no clue whether it's a runner pass and
even if they know it's a run he can run
inside outside he has speed he could
make it he could break away he can flare
out of the backfield you could put him
in motion
and have them lined up against the
safety this is the perfect weapon the
perfect weapon that every team wants
we've seen it a lot throughout the years
most of our kind of fall comes to memory
you have a mind just a bit there's a
bunch of other guys and think about this
in the 2017 Draft
JooJoo came in and when you look at his
stats he had 80 catches in the first
year 107 catches in the second year and
then 31 thus far it's impressive right
yeah because those weren't [ __ ]
JooJoo stats I just read you Christian
McCaffrey stats the first mm-hm 80
catches in year one a hundred and seven
catches in year two is 31 yeah we're
talking position list I didn't mean to
[ __ ] around what you like that I just
did that really I like that but at the
same point he has so he has 20 100
rushing yards in his career thus far and
he has 1,800 receiving yards thus far so
in in in too and not even a half years
that's nearly four thousand yards Brian
Westbrook
yeah he did impressive if you watch the
games he's the best player on the field
by every time every jump are most
explosive player on the field by far
he's become much more shippi Dalvin cook
is the only and say qualms when he's
healthy are the only guys
Dallben has looked pretty but Alvin has
looked out really really good he's
looked great but the thing about say
quanis I'd rather have McCaffrey say
Kwan has looked really good the problem
not even under product.this they don't
displace him as much so he's not as much
of a receiver right as either one of
those guys but hey I hope McCaffrey's
got a good agent I just hope naan
running back money that's hard to do
these days but he should he deserves it
he's playing like 99 percent of snaps he
deserves it I don't know who the backup
is that's because he's playing 99
percent of us now Reggie Boniface came
in he actually ran well and he had a
touchdown touchdown I covered him
Louisville he was a quarterback did you
so what's really funny is when you look
at how the Carolina Panthers built up
this team Curtis Samuel short shifty guy
everyone's like is he a real wide
receiver doesn't matter better than that
often
DJ more always explosive but is he a
wide receiver put him in that offense
they have a bunch of these weird parts
that can all work and I and I look at
Carolina I'm a little bit biased I bet
the Carolina over I bet them to win the
division but I look at what they've done
these last three weeks where it's you
beat Houston and Houston you beat
Jacksonville at home when Jacksonville's
come off a when where they just went
into Denver and won that's right
Carolina is getting it done right
they're playing well they're playing
well defense has been playing pretty
doggone good too
did you see the Mason Rudolph injury
yesterday I kind of rushed the Clipper
and that was scariest it's hate to see
that I hate to see that I mean again
when I go I go to the Eagles game every
week right and so every quarterback seen
to wear a mouthpiece man oh they should
because they get right he got rocked on
the chin if you had a mouthpiece I don't
think he goes out like this game is such
a I played the game for nine years and
obviously I played in high school and
cause before that when I go to the games
it scares me the physicality of football
so fast it's so fast so physical and
especially with guys get hit in the
mouth getting hit in the face getting
hit in the head that's just scary I
dealt with concussions my last couple
years and who knows how many before that
it's scary to see these guys go out like
that I just hope that they are willing
to take care of themself enough to not
come back until they're completely
healthy number one I did a little
research and I'm a little bit worried
about the rest of the NFL I'm seeing
something spread that has become more
dangerous than locusts this thing our
locusts dangerous I just mean like it
can it's it's it's a it's a spreadable
measles okay I didn't yeah okay keep
going
when you play the person mono sure
that's spreadable sure yeah when you
play the Patriots and Bill Belichick you
are franchise is not the same after it's
done I'm going to take you back in time
let's go to the playoffs last year okay
the Chargers come in
one on the road went ready to take on
the Patriots the Patriots pound the
Chargers so hard that the Chargers are
now off to such a bad start and the one
thing that everyone's done is they've
run all over them
the Patriots show your weakness yeah
then they go out there and they play the
Chiefs and after the Chiefs lost last
night to the Colts Patrick mahomes said
they did the same thing that the Lions
did which was to have their front four
and then play man a man across and who
did that first patron Bill Belichick
they show the way to beat you
the Rams they go to the Super Bowl and
they score three points and now no one's
falling for the play-action they're
forcing the Rams to run against them why
because Belichick shows the way to beat
you this season they explode they expose
the Steelers defense on in the slots and
they pretty much ended Ben
Roethlisberger's careers his last game
the Dolphins switched to rosin they got
rid of Fitzpatrick after that game after
they beat the Jets Jamal Adams the
supposed leader of that team went into a
tailspin canceling his radio show
because everything was exposed the bills
it's the only loss of the season the
Bills have had thus far but clearly the
Buffalo Bills have an antidote and
they're the only team that is used to it
and the Redskins Jay Gruden gets fired
when you play Bill Belichick they are so
pure in their success that all of your
massed [ __ ] comes to the forefront
the Patriots expose your weakness and
then everybody else hops on like hyenas
you have to eat the flesh the NFL's a
copycat league that makes sense and
balichek gives the blueprint a balichek
says okay Wistar what's the thing that
they don't want to do oh they want to
they want to throw that they don't want
to throw the ball to the flowers he's
okay let's make him throw the ball to
the slot receiver the only person they
can throw it to is a slot receiver
that's what he does he forces you to do
the things that you absolutely is the
last resource the things that you want
to do so all the things you think you do
good you run the ball good okay we'll
put a hundred guys in the box will stop
your run oh you want to throw it to your
number-one receiver guess what we'll
double-team him
entire game time make you figure it out
yes that's what they do good and they'll
by the way in situations they say you
know what we'll just change everything
and a half time well everything that we
did well ahead to the first half will
change it or on the sidelines you know
what these guys are doing well at this
situation what will play an entirely
different defense I mean just imagine we
played the Super Bowl against the
Patriots we're going into the game
preparing for three-four defense all
week long for two weeks I don't forget
it for two weeks we go into the game
saying they're gonna play a 3-4 they
come out in the 4-3 rocked our world
like hold on time out everything that
you've done is for nothing everything
that we've thought that was gonna happen
for the last two weeks they changed it
not that we weren't pretty you know we
weren't we couldn't handle it but at the
same time it's totally different so your
mindset as being comfortable as I tell
you interfere players want to be
comfortable it's gone you're like well
timeout that's not where we practice
again we want the scout team to get back
out there show us the look that we want
you to play yes they're gonna do the
complete opposite and I think you're
absolutely right
once one team exposes you especially the
Patriots teams are like you know what
the Patriots did this that any other we
may not have the same personnel but
we're definitely gonna try to scheme and
everybody has certainly tried it and I
think you're absolutely right
I was tweeting out like everybody else
after the Sunday night game about during
the Sun I gave up Patrick mahomes is
incredible that one run were that one
throw Eagles right yeah he does yeah and
then what happened was because they lost
to the Colts after the game everybody
was like oh this didn't age well
mahomes is mortal all that stuff and you
know what I thought if any other
quarterback went out there and lost a
guard or in the game and one of his top
two receivers was byron Pringle mm-hmm
they'd go oh he was up against a stacked
deck and and look Kelsey is my guy
Kelsey probably had one of his worst
games on a long time jumped a few and
and that doesn't happen but for you to
say that about mahomes when I watched
the game and he drives down the field by
himself after he gets his ankle stepped
on and puts them in a position to to
score a field goal and then go down
again I have no fear about the Kansas
City Chiefs they are going to be fine
because you know what they don't have
right now Tyree kill and let me tell you
something about Tyree kill oh I know
that you love me Col Hardman and I
loathe at DeMarcus Robinsons burst on
the scene ice there's a touchdown for
Byron Pringle when I talk to people on
the Chiefs they say that Tyree kill is a
different level hmm I'll CH every now
and then I'll text somebody and I'll go
hey is this guy faster than Tyree kill
and they laugh and they laugh they are
missing the if I know that I came out
and said Christian McCaffrey is the best
weapon in the sport and Tyree kill might
be two in terms of you can play him at
Ronnie make you play my wide receiver
and this whole let's play man-to-man
thisn it can't happen good luck there's
nobody can do it good luck so let me
just say that everybody that's enjoying
the Chiefs losing and I get it
it's nice when the undefeateds fall off
at the same point when Tyree comes back
you better watch your [ __ ] face here
here's Mike not because of the off the
field here isn't my concern for Kansas
City losing at home and you know what we
talked about it the home-field advantage
is different yeah so we're gonna have
home-field advantage a matter yeah but
it concerns me that their defense is
still so leaky that that's a big time so
when I when I'm watching the game last
night it said Chris Jones got hurt
midway through the game resulted a feast
yeah baby and that's the problem with
the Chiefs is they're like I look at the
Saints and I talk about them every week
about how deep their defensive line is
right the Raiders and the rotation they
can do the Chiefs are a lot like the
Eagles where I go I don't see any depth
and so a Fletcher Cox went down there
over there over that's what happened to
the Chiefs with Chris Jones and they and
it's it's a little bit scary that lack
of depth to things Chris Jones obviously
they can't stop the run and they can't
run and I know my home was this magical
yeah I just know that at some point in
the season you're gonna have to run the
football when the other team knows that
you're gonna run in and Erie's teams
just haven't been able to have that
consistent run game this that's
surprising this is the time of the year
where Andy like punched the holes that I
got to stop using those metaphors
where Amy Reed came out and begin
the year and his game plans were perfect
and his offense was able to do whatever
it was and he and then this is the time
of the year where it starts to you know
it's a little it starts to get to 24 to
21 instead of the thirty seven to twenty
one course and you need that balance
what was it like to experience that
firsthand it's terrible because you know
as a as a football player you're saying
what can I do to help the team if you
want me to block 60 times the game I'll
do that I don't care but also I also
feel like you need to be able to run the
ball then that's the upsetting part
question because you're like Andy just
run it we have good players we have a
really good offensive line we have a
good running back and defense are only
playing five guys in the box because we
throw the ball every play we probably
just try to run it how about that I mean
we try to do that I have a might be a
dumb question before the year and you
read said that Eric the enemy is going
to be calling the place and my dumb
question is why do we keep calling us in
and Erie defense why are we not saying
this is Eric the enemy and and giving
him credit for what's what they've been
able to do this know why because he made
the offense he also he diagrammed it he
comes up with the plays Eric be enemy
might be calling the place and I don't
know that a hundred percent of the time
be enemies alone with the head saying I
think I'm not think and not and I was
with EB for a long time he's a good dude
very very smart great thought process
guys for football so I'm not concerned
with him calling the plays but in weird
part about it he's they're all running
back and then still that's what so I
think I think Andy does that for a
couple different reasons my honest
opinion is that he understands the
offensive coordinators get jobs when
their offense does he's trying to get
his guy John so I think that's kind of
his gift to Eric the enemy in my opinion
but I also think that Andy is the
orchestrator of this offense he wants it
to be 80/20 he wants to be 80% pass 20%
run we can you have that guy on any
Center you can have it that way I'll
tell you this there are times in
november/december you're gonna have to
be able to stop the run and run the
football they can't do either one that
was always my fear of rooting for Andy
Reid too was knowing that we were gonna
get to the playoffs like a game against
the Saints and they were just gonna
pound us yeah and and it's the most
helpless feeling that you can have well
if you can stay on the field which the
Colts were able to do the culture on the
field I think it was
I want to say 37 in 37 minutes and 15
seconds to 22 minutes and 45 seconds you
look at the second half because I looked
this up this morning I believe that
Chiefs had the ball for seven minutes
total in the second half the time
despaired in the second half was 22 31
for the Colts 7:30 for the Chiefs it's
in in it's weird when you think about
just looking but also home this is not
just a chief issue the Indianapolis
Colts offensive line in quitting Nelson
if you sent me above the wall to fight
White Walkers I want the cold song I
want those boys yeah
because those are the guys the the best
thing about quit Nelson is this not him
Hines who I think is Brian Westbrook 2.0
for the critic really good sir out at NC
State fast quick spin move gets a huge
first down the fourth cone you know the
only person that was there to pick him
up quit Nelson dude ran like 30 yards
quit Nelson is out there and a tank top
in the winner Quinton Nelson is out
there in full face paint and he what
happens is is if you guys remember back
to the draft in which quit Nelson went
sixth there was a lot of rumors that
they're gonna go middle linebacker
because his defense sucks and they were
thinking they might go row Quon Smith
they might grow Jermaine Edmonds or
Terrell Edmonds Tremayne and they ended
up taking Quinton Nelson at six and what
that has done for that franchise has
been seismic it has in my opinion lifted
up the work ethic of everybody else on
that team but when you have an offensive
lineman that can move people like Cris
Collinsworth was talking about two gaps
yeah every play changes things it's
insane what it makes Marlon Mac look
like a superhuman at the running back
position were a couple years ago even is
Marilyn Mac the guy you know Jacobi
perset who takes a little bit more time
than most more typical absolutely and he
instills fear on the defense every time
he plays you know there was times
yesterday I'm saying that the Chiefs
just get some pressure just get around
the quarterback affect them couldn't do
it just gonna do it can't get there
couldn't Frank Clark couldn't do
anything you know who was the nastiest
offensive lineman not just that
you've ever played with but that you saw
on the field the nastiest offensive
lineman was Larry Allen that's the guy
that everyone and I remember seeing him
this is funny we're at the Pro Bowl my
first time at the Pro Bowl and so this
is my first time really being around
these guys and so I was at out front
waiting on my car to come Larry Allen in
Lincoln Kennedy get out of this Lincoln
this big old car and both of them had to
be 350 plus I don't know Lincoln might
been for the car is like current it's
it's on the ground on the ground but
what's aware of plaques okay Larry Allen
one of the coolest do whatever dip in
his sock just just nasty that's what you
want in the offensive line some I don't
care around look like I'm spittin that's
what you want quit Nelson quit Nelson is
not only do I not need these sleeves I
don't need the entire sides of this
shirt no quitting Nelson to someone that
is I care about winning football games
if it quit Nelson would do interviews
Brian and when people would give him
credit for turning around the offensive
line he would get angry and because it's
not just me yeah quit Nelson is I've
never been so certain of a hall-of-famer
in his second year mhm
it's unbelievable stay healthy young man
so I went back and I looked at my notes
that I was looking at before the season
and I kept talking about this these
teams and how they perform in one score
games yeah and how it's not transferable
to the next season and there was a stat
where teams that won five more than they
lost in one score game so if you went
five and oh seven and two six and one
and it goes back in the last twenty
seven times that this has happened those
teams the next year when 89 and 111 in
one score games so the year before they
were 173 and 38 the next year 89 and 111
and there were four teams last season
that did amazing in one score games and
I say guess what it probably won't
continue and I just wanted to say we're
five weeks in how's it going so far the
Cowboys the Rams the Dolphins and the
Chargers thus far and one score games
Dallas is Owen one the Rams are one and
one Miami hasn't been
one score game and the Chargers are one
and three in one score games so thus far
those those four teams that probably
want to combined 20 and o or or 25 and
five are now two and five in one score
games do you think the reason is the
reason is is that that's just not
something that's bankable I'd like to
hear your football reason well they
can't ramp it up back it up I mean I
think that when you win or one score
game I'm not saying that it's luck but
someone has to do with luck is this
sometime the ball bounces the right way
yes and when the ball bounces the right
way in one season
it just keeps happening it's almost just
like dropping the ball it just becomes
contagious you dropped one you might
drop three more it's contagious when
things good things happen for you they
usually just keep happening the next
year it a verge is out and it goes the
other way always I mean it just like
it's just like the penalties and
everybody always blames around all their
ups hate us yeah they hate you this year
but next year all the calls may go your
way no down so it's it kind of just
averages its way out that's how football
generally is that the one outlier you
were saying I don't have any stats to
support this the one outlier would say
they're good teams usually aren't in one
score games usually they're up by ten
they're up by eight there by nine
whatever that whatever it is they're
usually up and so they're usually
winning by more than one score so these
statistics don't apply to the pitch is
there what about twenty all the time so
it's a little bit different with here if
you're an average team and you just
happen to win by one score by three
points whatever it is usually the next
year you're in probably still average
the ball bounces the other way one other
thing that I saw in my notes was I wrote
toe note to myself
don't forget drew breezes arm got really
tired at the end of last season but you
know what this injury perfect might be
the reason it's perfect the New Orleans
Saints are able to go through the
playoffs in the Super Bowl with Drew
Brees playing it the best he's ever
played it's perfect
he is gonna get let's say maybe four
weeks with him out there throw him by
himself but four to five to six weeks of
not putting any game stress on that arm
not wearing it down and in a weird way I
think that this team has proved
- drew that you don't need to make the
crazy throw to carry us right now that
teddy bridgewater has taken what's been
given to him yeah
against Tampa he hit the shots over the
top couple a couple three balls down the
frogs he dumped it underneath because
that's what they gave em hmm
but this defense and this offensive line
I didn't see a Buccaneer sniffing teddy
bridgewater last week all we talked
about was Shaquille Barrett and all that
the Saints defense injured two
Buccaneers offensive linemen yesterday
because that's how physical they are we
still though see the Saints and we think
in them as this high-scoring team but
through this injury
I think the Saints team has more
confidence in themselves but also Drew
Brees is gonna have four to five weeks
of non wear and tear that might carry
through the championship game of the
Super Bowl that they might not have had
last year two teams that are playing a
little bit different Green Bay and the
the Saints they're winning differently
they're playing more to the defense of
running the ball obviously Green Bay had
a big game from Aaron Jones yesterday
but they're running the ball a little
bit more they're saving their
quarterback from having wearing T I'm
gonna give you a stat I'm glad you
brought that up 2018
six out of the first 11 the first 11
games of the season drew rains Drew
Brees is over 250 passes passing yards
and one interception in the first 11
games right great after week 11 two
times only two so you turn my week 11
all the way into the last two games of
the season in the playoffs he only had
two times he was over 250 yards he had
six interceptions every week from week
11 until the end of the year meaning the
two playoff games the only week he
didn't have an interception was week 15
so not only was his arm tired he didn't
have the yards but he was also throwing
the ball to the other team so you're
absolutely right this may be the saving
grace for the the Saints o only if Drew
Brees comes back in is the Drew Brees
that we knew and he doesn't start
throwing the ball to the other team the
other side of that is that part of a
team thought process is you know what
Teddy's pretty playing pretty good and
we're winning with them and I'm not by
any means saying that they're not gonna
go to bring Zac
saying that I'm not saying that I just
need I also understand that it takes
time for a quarterback to ramp his way
back up and sometimes the team starts
here because you're building your way
out sort of engorge in it yeah it may
fall back they put Melvin Gordon and
that running offense look like [ __ ] also
the coordinator Sean Payton may say we
have the old Drew Brees back um let's go
back to the way we're doing it before
and your team might not be built that
way because I'll tell you right now this
team is built differently than it was
two three years ago my only concern
about the Saints is they're going to
reach a time where they're gonna need I
think a power running game they don't
have that and Mark Ingram was that and
latavius Murray is none but I do look at
the fact that everyone was talking to
wide receiver but I look at the fact
that they have Thomas chimera and then
we saw the rebirth again yesterday their
tight end who I can't [ __ ] remember
his name Jared Cook yeah and I go three
weapons is enough you can you can move
the you can move it with three weapons
and then you know get the occasional
performances from the other guy yeah but
I know that you think that Teddy's
earning himself a lot of money right now
well I just think that he signed a
one-year deal of seven seven and a half
million bucks in March he is playing
himself you know really good into an
opportunity to to get some money this
offseason
he's a highest-paid backup quarterback
in the league right now but my question
is if you're Teddy and you have this
team that you've now played on the Jets
the Vikings
has he been anywhere else I don't think
so Jets Vikings no that's it yeah but
you've seen you know a Vikings team
where that did not give a [ __ ] about
offense mhm
Mike Zimmer cared about the defense and
he looked at Teddy and he said don't
[ __ ] it up then you went to the Jets and
you saw how abysmal that was and now
you're in New Orleans yeah and you're
sitting in a room with Drew Brees yeah
Sean Peyton yeah and Sean Peyton much
like Bill a check did - Josh McDaniel
Sean Payton is probably looking at at
Teddy Bridgewater and going listen Brees
has like two years left you're next yeah
come in and let's continue this I know
that there's gonna be other teams that
might want to throw money at him but I
don't stability in the NFL with a coach
like Sean Payton is rare rare who who do
you think would go after him I have a
bunch of teens in you know just thought
process Miami you never know
I think Tampa Bay stays with Jameis but
I was like why would Teddy go to Miami
as a free agent isn't that right I know
but I'm just telling you teams that need
a court of law change that may be in the
market and you never know what happens
and I'm still not the biggest believer
in Teddy if you start throwing around
money you start throwing around 100 100
million guaranteed that's not happening
start throwing around money who else
Miami Chicago Tampa Bay I'm still kind
of 50/50 on Tampa Bay Tennessee Chicago
I mentioned them Denver I mean there's a
couple teams out there four or five
teams that I would say he has a
legitimate chance of going there and
they throw him some money because if I'm
telling I'm saying but you know what I'm
kind of waiting my turn
turning swiping I'll be he'll be turning
27 next month I kind of waited my turn I
don't want to wait two more years and
who's to say that Drew Brees has a good
next two years and then I'll get a
chance because not only is he gonna
chance to play he's getting a chance to
being paid and maybe when he's 30 maybe
nobody wants to pay him that I think I
want my guaranteed money now who does
the way I look at it who do you think
it's gonna be harder for to retire drew
Brees or Tom Brady which one of them do
you think holds on for the longest I
think Tom holds one more and I'll tell
you what drew has experienced some
injuries and when you get those injuries
as you get older you start to think of
your mortality you also start to think
you know I could be doing this and when
you're out and I know he's working hard
I know he's doing everything he can to
rehab while you start spending more time
with your family and you start to like
that and I'm not saying Tom doesn't like
his family but he's but he's playing
he's locked in all day long 14 hours 15
hours a day but when you start spending
time with your family just off the field
stuff you start to like it drew Brees
has a couple three you know young boys
I'm sure they're playing football doing
a lot of different things you start to
think you know this ain't so bad and
when you had that time off it starts to
wear on you a little bit and you started
enjoying that time off and
why because an injuries the time off I
think the drew brees probably gets out
of there a little bit sooner than Tom
Brady neither of them are gonna want to
know of course not you know why would
you if I could have played longer I
absolutely will however I played at a
position where you know yourself life
you're getting hit so much yeah if I'm a
quarterback and I'm only getting to hit
two three times a game that's not that I
could take that that's easy easy we keep
making rules to protect me
um easy stuff speaking about your bears
I got a prediction for you Oh tell me
more I believe that the Bears and their
fans are about to enter the tailspin ooh
and I think it's gonna get really bad
okay so they have a bye this week okay
after getting pushed around and
embarrassed because all I heard last
week Brian Westbrook was that chase
Daniel was better than Mitchell Cho
Biscay every radio show I went on every
TV show I watched knees better mmm-hmm
well if he's better than true Biscay
then that team is royally screwed
because you know what the bears are
gonna watch on their bye week this is
gonna set the tone for the misery that's
about to come in the Houston Texans are
going to the Kansas City Chiefs
deshaun Watson is going to play mahomes
the two quarterbacks
and they passed up on to get Metrobus
key so that's how they're spending their
bye week okay after that they then go to
the Saints on the war with Warren sharp
we we dove into the statistics that home
teams after a bye are awful the last two
years
they're 4 and 18 22 % on the spread so
so we know that teams are bad at home
after a body zap rising number I mean
that's that's because you guys get all
[ __ ] cozy you eat your [ __ ]
chocolate chip cookie does and you look
around you're like maybe I just want to
quit now
yeah that's what you guys do when you're
by week right is that what do you do
vacation would be nice you know she milk
a little pancake that's it yeah yeah
well heavy go to Cabo absolutely
definitely going to cop Oh like and
that's what's so funny and I'm gonna get
back to think about like Jamal Adams
like I went to Turks and Caicos yeah we
[ __ ] saw uh-huh
of course you did yeah enjoy yourself
yeah have a grid of the season yeah
think about that but so they they have
the bye week they watch moms at once
right then they face the saints who I
believe is the best team in the NFC at
home okay then they host the Chargers
who are who have over the last year's
but any better road team than a home
team and are gonna be desperate I'm
shocked about a charge that may go to
Philadelphia then they host the Lions
then at the Rams who are gonna want
revenge for their loss last year and
then then the last four games for the
Bears Cowboys Cowboys and Chiefs at home
yep Packers and Vikings on the road
that's right I'm it's tough the
regression Bears are finishing this year
with seven or eight wins the Bears I
think they they thought that they were
to have a running game to support the
quarterback they don't have that they
thought the defense can carry them the
entire way and and they've done a pretty
good job thus far but at some point
every defense I don't care how good they
are if your offense could do nothing
they're gonna get tired and we're seeing
their offense look bad and not only not
only here's the thing if offensively if
you could just punt
every time every possession let's say
you have 12 possessions in the game you
score 10 points of touch down on one
possession of field goal in the other
you know it is late elaborate possession
other nine positions you punt and you
have a good defense you'll win they're
turning the ball over
chased Daniel throw the ball to the
other team if you do that you can't win
I don't care especially with a bad
offense like this what a great defense
you can't win if we're seeing it right
here and I think you're absolutely right
it doesn't go bad it doesn't get better
the other thing is this they also had
the kiss of death
in terms of offseason awards they won
coach of the year yeah and I don't know
if they want executive of the year but
waiting you win that award those coaches
always like it doesn't work out a few
years later it's so funny well guess
what happens to those coaches especially
the way Matt taking that off has kind of
took a lot of teams by surprise all
offseason every team in their division
every team that's gonna play them this
year are trying to figure out how to
stop them that's what they're doing and
now the little trick plays it to Ari
Cohen guess what those don't work
anymore
no getting the ball to your quarterback
and I know that wasn't work anymore not
only that they traded all of their draft
picks for Khalil Mack yeah
which means all of their future is gone
and no future it's high praise high
price players and they're not gonna be
able to keep the Bears had to win this
here had to because of the way that
their contracts are set up in the
structure of the team they're gonna
reach a point soon and I believe they're
gonna have to be the team that when sure
Biscay comes up they go we can't give
you that big deal we're not built that
way well not only are you not built that
way too risky just hasn't been good
enough no and they're gonna have all the
reasonings of the other games Cowboys
Packers Cowboys we now look at their
first three wins Giants Washington Miami
for gays now look at their last two
losses yeah Green Bay and New Orleans
and sure the Cowboys put up 24 points
whatever it was but really the game was
already in hand mm-hmm it was already
like 24 to nothing that defense that I
believe was gonna be really really good
got ran all over I'm shocked by that cuz
I think they have 2/3 of the best
linebackers to at least two of the best
linebackers in leagues I'm not gonna
inclusion on leonis that shocked me that
Vanda rested Smith where were they at it
building the wrong holes over running
did the running backs it shocked me that
a team in the Packers who haven't really
been able to run the football all day
long I'm such an eye on the ball down
there think about this you know what
team ran all over the Cowboys last year
the Tennessee Titans and who was the
offensive coordinator Matt Lafleur who's
now the head coach of the Packers if you
remember the Titans came out there and
beat the [ __ ] out of the Cowboys 28 to
fourteen and Mariota and Derrick Henry
were every what but but the Titans were
set up to run the football this team the
Green Bay Packers are not set up to run
a football they haven't been able to run
all season I had the Packers win in the
north and they are performing at a level
that this is exactly mean you go into
Dallas without Davante Adams that's
right and Aaron Jones who this fan base
has all begging to be featured goes off
Aaron Rodgers is still sidearm in it
[ __ ] hitting tight ends on wheel
routes and the Smith Brothers were back
at it again
mm-hmm all over the place man the
packers but who got hurt Preston Smith
got hurt a little bit
za'darius was cramping up the entire
second he kept in kept going in and not
you know I'll say there's a way to get
face time I won't hear he got a lot of
face time all in Zach's face I speaking
of death now time think about it
isn't it terrible that they put him in a
situation that Jerry Jones has handled
this thing completely wrong I mean I
would argue that he's actually done a
great job I think that this is because
everybody wanted to give a deal after
the [ __ ] Giants game I'll tell you
why he's terrible jerison because as the
players didn't dad could say whatever he
wants he's thinking about this contract
every game don't get hurt and don't mess
up
mmm that's no way to play duck has to be
thinking about this well if I play good
then I'm probably getting more money and
if I play bad I'll get less so now
everybody last week the first three
games everybody's saying he's 36 37 a
couple drinks yeah probably get as much
money as you can and now they're saying
oh 25 24 or 20 imade they're going down
so this is type two part this is a type
of pressure that you don't what I
remember I was going through a
negotiation with and III heap in Joe
Banner
throughout the season in every game
you're like first of all at the
quarterback position there's a definite
different level of pressure on you every
single week in every game it ramps up
more and more that has to be feeling it
especially with them losing their last
two games he has to be feeling it this
team has put them in an unwinnable
position because they won't either pay
him or say you know we're gonna talk
about it end of the season
not because you're gonna win they never
they haven't even said we'll talk about
at the end of the year yet this is a bad
position for this football team because
you need dak to play well in the
pressure of you know continue to evolve
as a player and the pressure of this
contract has to be weighing on this kid
that's a terrible position for the
quarterback oh and by the way guess what
they can't run the ball anymore because
their offensive lineman you got two or
three of them hurt every single remember
two weeks ago when you gave the Eagles
0.5 percent yes and I we were both down
on him mm-hmm
and the Cowboys were three you know and
they look good running away we weren't
being real with their conferences for
one and two
yeah yeah it's just my one thing is is
that we overreacted to those three wins
and but I want to say this about NFL
it's the most overreacting league in all
of sports they play once a week it's 16
games the sample sizes are small and
every week we crown people and we kill
them and we don't think about
perspective yeah we work and when I say
we I mean like football fans football
fans were killing Kirk Cousins after the
Chicago game of course yet they were
playing in Chicago against the Bears
yeah people
the reporters felt the need to question
deshaun Watson and his ability to throw
deep because they lost to the Panthers
the very next week Kirk Cousins an Adam
Thielen dial up a hundred and fifty plus
yards right the very next week DeAndre
Hopkins completes all those passes in
Florida Hopkins and they put up 53
points and but everyone goes back into
this and doesn't even acknowledge what
they said the week before yeah it's
[ __ ] crazy
no this is a matchup League that's the
beauty of the league though and that's
the beauty of being a fan that every
week you can say you know what I hate my
team right now they lost to Miami
Dolphins and next week you brought oh I
love these guys they beat the Green Bay
Packers that's the beauty of the lead
that's the beauty of our game one game a
week and you have all week to dissected
to be on to be all you start on Monday
you say I hate them and by Friday you
love them again that's the beauty of our
game so if we care about context would
you agree that the Dolphins are bad yes
would you agree that the Jets with Luke
Falk are bad terrible would you agree
that Washington is bent absolutely would
you agree that the Steelers defense has
really been disappointing looks terrible
okay we need to have a real talk about
the Patriots because that's who the
Patriots have faced and the Patriots
have the easiest schedule in the NFL
only gets easier yep they face the
Giants at home on Thursday night then
they go back to Luke Falk to play him
they still have another game against the
Dolphins this year my thing about the
Patriots is right now we are talking
about how they are the greatest defense
that the world has ever seen and
frankly it's unbelievable and the
statistics and how they're holding
people to like six points a game is
absurd I just want to read this because
I was thinking about this last night and
I'm curious what you think Brian
Westbrook the the quarterbacks they
faced have been Luke Falk mm-hmm Colt
McCoy who had little to no prep and did
not throw a pass in a preseason game
beforehand they played half a game of
matt barkley and josh allen threw a few
pics to them and they played ryan
fitzpatrick and they played ben
roethlisberger who like did not look
right at all in that game not
comfortable this defense
are we over inflating them a little bit
I think that normally we can say that
we're over inflating them right but you
always got to give that team I know up
there I know that benefit of the doubt
I think defensively they got some good
players there are many they got some
players that can go linebacker on every
level my back our defensive line is
secondary so I don't think that we're
overinflated them I think that by simply
saying because they beat these teams on
this schedule that they're the greatest
thing on earth I think that's a little
bit much I think that they have some
huge flaws Luke [ __ ] Matt Barkley these
are just I think there's averages you're
not average quarterback they're just
guys these are guys that shouldn't be on
roster they're just guys they're so
they're just guys so they haven't beat
anybody Michael as far as the strength
of their schedule however they've also
shown throughout their time that yeah
we're gonna just not just barely win
we're gonna run through you which we
thought the Eagles should have done
yesterday
and clearly they didn't look as crisp as
I think we should we all thought they
should have been especially all
offensively I think the Patriots are
special I think they have special
players defensively I think all finished
offensively they're gonna have some
issues I think that Tom Brady shows and
showing a little age I think their
offensive line has been decimated by
injury Tom Brady's reached a point and
this is not a knock on Tom Brady he's
every reason to do this when Tom Brady
has pressure right in his face yeah he
falls yes and you know what I get it
because in his mind we're the Patriots
if its third and 12 we'll still find a
way to pick it up
know what he said that's he's saying
that he's also saying you know what it's
better to have me in this game than
anybody else and even if I take this
sack it's better to have me then to
anybody else
and I'm this important to this football
team and he's absolutely right he's
absolutely right he's absolutely right
so yeah
really we watched Eli do it for 15 years
but a little different comparison there
but I I that's why I'm just seeing
people talking about the statistics of
the Patriots and it's just something
that Warren kind of spotlighted to me
last year where people were talk about
how good the Titans were and then you
looked at like which quarterbacks the
Titans actually faced it's sometimes it
says incredible situation where you you
just you lock into this schedule that
you keep facing these like quarterbacks
that are backups and it inflates the
perception of your defense well you got
a look at over the course of time
playing in the AFC East I mean it's
pretty it feels good to be the Patriots
because you know you got six games are
you gonna win and leave me it's a
chicken and egg or the have the bills
the Jets and the Dolphins been bad
because the Patriots have like
embarrassed them every year or are they
just bad franchises that have helped out
the page well I think they're bad
franchise to have helped out to patients
but I would like to see the stats on how
many coaches those teams in that
division have gone through since 2001 I
mean it comes difficult doing the last
two I mean that's crazy I just mean
that's a crazy amount but that's
probably right anything else you want to
get out and this month but I got a part
set notes about everything man you can
always save them for Wednesday I'm
saving from we're gonna have a pretty
good guest on Wednesday we had a little
surprise guest you like you like
surprising me isn't it fun it kind of
surprises I don't like surprise birthday
I just don't like saying the guests
before they come because then if they
don't show up yeah I'm gonna be
disappointing we'll talk about my mynsc
team's later we'll wait we'll wait till
perfect cuz the guy that's gonna come in
is a big-time [ __ ] talker yeah good good
we'll talk about my NSE teens that I
think have a chance
still at the Super Bowl there's not a
lot of them there's some there's not a
lot all right be Wes let's go man hey if
you ever see me eating candy yell at me
why no I want you to be fat man like I
like the chubby UI like that's cool
what
yeah you feel chubby the right Oh big
time oh well that's [ __ ] out that you
you pretty much like your chubby listen
their needs on every good show there
needs to be a skinny guy that's me in a
chubby guy and that's we're gonna be two
skinny guys I'm happy for you though
actually it's gonna be a jacked guy me
you can enjoy a skinny guy you you know
if you if you start getting too jack
I'll start lifting more but I don't I
don't want to do that and we just become
two meatheads just just in here curling
weights and that's an interesting take
yeah
mate keep doing it we tried the gym
that's gonna show that's your meat head
that's good alright play for Brian
Westbrook the rocket man nice the lef
koe man and you know what send us in
some weird questions for the round table
on Wednesday in burrs really good at
coming out with them but if you guys
have some when I read it I'll read the
name of who put it in there too so hit
us up at love Co show for Westbrook I'm
love go I'll let you later
[Music]